to be Innovative you have to experiment
if you want to have more invention you
need to do more experiments per week per
month per year per decade it's that
simple you cannot invent without
experimenting and here's the other thing
about experiments lots of them fail if
you know it's going to work in advance
it is not an experiment what happens in
big organizations that Amazon's a big
organization now too the Air Force is a
big organization is that we start to
confuse experimentation with operational
excellence so operational excellence is
one of our four key principles at Amazon
we're building a fulfillment center
we've built over 150 large fulfillment
centers around the world now we know how
to do that that is not an experiment if
we build the 151st fulfillment center
and screw it up that's just a failure
that's not the kind of failure we're
seeking we want failures where we're
trying to do something new untested
never proven that's a real experiment
and they come in all scale sizes the key
to experiment mountain is expecting to
suck just expect to suck expect it not
to work out expect it to be a total
disaster expect to suck
which gives yourself the permission to
go and try we're holding ourselves back
from trying because you may not expect
to be great but expect to be pretty good
I think this is a problem for a lot of
entrepreneurs is you have an idea you
have a dream you don't think you're
going to be the next Jeff Bezos maybe
yes but maybe no you're going to make
your own YouTube channel you're not
going to be great on camera but you
expect to be pretty good
you know you don't expect to be Bezos
but you expect to be pretty good in your
business and what ends up happening is
you start and you realize oh my gosh I'm
not only
not Bezos level I'm I'm terrible
I see it all the time people who are
starting their YouTube channels they
don't expect to be terrible on camera
they don't expect to be whoever you
think is a great on-camera personality
and then they record themselves and if
they thought they'd be like an 8 out of
10 they don't expect to be 10 they think
they'd be eight
and then they watch it back like oh my
gosh I'm a two
I'm a two out of ten and then they stop
and they never release the video they
never try the next thing because they're
convinced that they just suck that they
suck as a human
and that they'll never get the skills
well how do you get the skills by
practicing by doing just because you're
a two out of ten now doesn't mean you
can't become an eight or a nine or a ten
how do you get there how do you go from
a two to an eight or nine or ten at the
thing that you want to be great at by
practicing by learning by doing not just
by researching and studying and watching
other people you have to get into the
trenches and start to create and start
to make that's how you move
but people are too afraid to fail that
they don't even try
you're so afraid to fail that you don't
even try
and the way through it is expecting to
suck
I am right now learning about nfts
and now I know enough to be dangerous
about nfts but two months ago I didn't I
knew nothing I didn't know what it's
what it stood for non-fungible I don't
even know what a fungible token
non-taught nothing made sense I didn't
understand what wag me meant I didn't
understand what lfg meant I didn't
understand what hoddle meant I didn't
know the difference between Bitcoin or
ethereum I didn't know what I meant a
mask wallet was all of this stuff zero
idea and the more I I just looked at it
from the outside the more I got
stressed out confused overwhelmed I
don't understand any of this stuff I
feel like a total beginner and so I'm
not going to learn it
and I want to be the person who jumps on
things who learns things it doesn't
accept scary difficult or hard as good
enough reasons for me not to do it so I
dove in
and I asked all of those stupid
questions and I learned not just by
reading about it but by launching my own
nft projects and putting it out there
and starting to work with people I went
into the different discords and Twitter
I didn't even know what Discord was I
wasn't using Discord
nft land is Discord and Twitter I had to
install Discord and get active on it I
had to reignite my Twitter account like
you guys use Twitter I haven't used
Twitter for years but Twitter is where
the game is at so I'm picking up my
Twitter game again and I'm asking what
seems to be stupid questions I'm asking
all the beginner questions and I'm
launching my own nft project to learn
to understand and now I know enough to
be dangerous I'm not an expert at it but
I know enough to be dangerous
and that happened in a relatively short
amount of time because I was willing to
experiment and I was willing to expect a
sec at the beginning I'm gonna go in be
a total Noob right total total newbie
total beginner ask the questions and
then I'm going to learn through that
process and get better at it you can
surprise yourself with how much you can
learn
surprise yourself with how much you can
learn at the beginning if you're just
willing to detach yourself that just
because you suck at a skill doesn't mean
that you suck as a human
this is where we get stuck it's like oh
I suck at that therefore I suck and I'm
never gonna get better so I'm going to
stop and go do something else that makes
me feel good
instead say no I suck at this skill and
I feel good for trying and I'm going to
keep getting better at this so that I
can I can improve my skill from a two to
a two and a half to three to a five to
an eight to a ten right so how do we
start to do it how do we start to give
ourselves more permission to experiment
give ourselves permission to fail give
ourselves permission to suck how do we
do it
step number one trust your ideas
trusted the ideas that come to you are
good trust that idea that you're
thinking about right now is good just do
a quick gut check is are you trying to
rip people off are you trying to serve
and try to help are you trying to just
take their money put in your bank
account and go buy your boat or you're
trying to actually do some good right if
you're watching this channel hopefully
you're in the second category or you're
trying to serve you're trying to help
you're trying to create something of
value so if that is your intention then
trust your ideas stop holding yourself
back stop saying that you can't do it
stop finding all the reasons in your
head that you cannot take action because
your Heroes have done more with less
than what you already have right now
whoever your heroes are whoever you look
up to Jeff Bezos whoever Oprah Winfrey
whoever they started with less than what
you have right now they could do it you
can do it too
you can
so if the idea is a good one it's it's
it's it feels right it's heart Centric
you want to serve you want to bring
value to people then trust that idea
trust it step number two immediate
action
immediate immediate immediate action the
problem is we get stuck in overthinking
over planning over preparing over
strategizing over asking other people
well what do you think I should do stop
that immediate action what's the first
thing that you can do
if you want to get an nfts go join
somebody's Discord go launch your own
single nft you're going to make tons of
mistakes perfect launch it you want to
launch a podcast great start your
podcast today you want to create a
YouTube channel awesome pull out your
phone record your video You're a
YouTuber now right you want to launch a
fashion business perfect create a logo
make a t-shirt like just start it
doesn't have to be anything great just
start the biggest thing for most people
that's missing is just momentum it's all
of these things stuck in your head and
not enough being created in the world
and to get all this organized and
structured and actually making sense you
have to actually put something out
so trust your ideas that they're good
that they're of value that they're they
will serve and then set number two is do
something about it immediate in the
moment action let's go stop overthinking
it and today something has to happen and
then step number three is just expect to
suck expect to suck expect it not to
work out expect not to make money on
this expect no comments no replies no
feedback expect to to just fail expect
it to be a total failure if you expect
that going in then you're not
you're not surprised when it doesn't
work out and you're not taking it
personally that you tried this thing and
nobody cares about it right now
you're lowering the burden for what has
to happen for you to feel good about
yourself
if you only feel good when you win then
you will never try
if you will only take
a yes and enter that competition enter
that race or do that thing if you know
that you're going to win you will never
try you you will stay stuck doing the
easy stuff for the rest of your life and
never accomplish what you're capable of
never hit anywhere close to your
potential
so you have to expect it just to suck
and again by it's sucking by getting a
sucky result
it actually means that you're amazing
doesn't mean that you suck as a human
you only suck as a human because if you
don't try
to reward yourself for trying
search reward yourself for the effort
so to reward yourself for doing the
things that are outside your comfort
zone that are scary for you scary
difficult hard right you think of that
you're doing it and then you reward
yourself saying man I did that I can't
believe I did that was crazy
even though it didn't work out because
you know that if you kept trying and
kept learning and kept improving
that it of course is going to work out
you just have to show up with that level
of energy and enthusiasm and intent
every day
the difference between where you are
right now where you want to be is how
many experiments you're putting out
there
how many ideas that you've got that
you're trying
because you will not be rewarded for the
ideas that stay stuck in your head more
importantly you don't want to get to the
end of your life and look back and say I
had all these ideas but I was too afraid
of failing that I never tried any of
them
Wayne Dyer says don't let that song Die
within you
you got to play the song while you're
alive
you've got a great song in you
let's get it out to the world
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
how do you handle these Mavericks that
you know how do you how do you protect
them from the institutions destroying
them well I think it has to be culture
you have to teach the value that these
people bring but also I would push hard
on the Mavericks to say you also have to
be organized you can't just be a crazy
person you know that so it's like it's
fine to be a Maverick but you know write
your ideas sure so sell your ideas
persuade create the conditions where the
ideas can blossom you can't get anything
done if you're not uh you know if you're
just a purely a creative person with
zero organizational skills you're
probably not going to get much done are
you stubborn on vision and flexible on
details the um you really can't
accomplish anything important if you're
not stubborn on Vision because things
that are important take a long time to
take teams you can't do it by yourself
and so you really need to
need to have a crisp idea of the vision
you need to stay incredibly relentless
on that Vision but you need to be
flexible on the details because
you've got to be experimental to
accomplish anything important and that
means you're going to be wrong a lot and
so you're going to try something on your
way to that vision and that's going to
be the wrong thing the wrong decision
you're going to have to back up
take a little course correction and try
again and so you cannot be stubborn on
the details you have to be flexible on
the details a young person starting
their career
I think there are probably a lot of
things some of them are very well known
and people have heard them many times
they're still true one of those is you
should always focus on a young person
should find something that they're
passionate about to do and that's not
going to surprise anyone it's it's a
clear thing to do it's very hard if you
don't love your work you're never going
to be great at it
um I think the other thing I would
suggest to any young person even before
they start their career is to really
think about their choices
because I find young people and I I when
I was young I had I made this mistake
too
you can get very fixed on your gifts so
everybody has gifts you know you you
have gifts and you have things that you
didn't get gifted maybe you're extremely
beautiful maybe you're extremely good at
mathematics maybe you there are a lot of
things that you can be given
but those things can confuse you because
they're not the things that construct
your life it's your choices that
construct your life not your gifts you
can celebrate your gifts be proud of
them be happy of them actually don't be
proud of them be be celebratory of them
because you can't be proud because
they're gifts they were given to you you
didn't earn them you can only be proud
of the things you earn and so as I got
older I started to realize I wasn't
proud of my gifts I was always good at
school school is always easy for me and
I was always proud that I was a great
student I got A's in all my classes I
was good at math all of that and I
thought I thought that's who I was but
it's not true those are the things that
are gifts what was hard for me is
deciding to work hard deciding to use my
gifts in certain ways to challenge
myself to do things that I didn't think
I could do to put myself in
uncomfortable situations we all get I
would say to a young person
you can choose a life of ease and
comfort or you can choose a life of
service and Adventure which one of those
when you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of we
would all love all of our numbers to be
smooth lines up and to the right and
that would be terrific but that's not
how it works you know you know the those
numbers are are output measures and you
I mean I guess you could try to manage
your quarterly earnings very precisely
but I think personally that would be a
mistake you know most of the work that
we put into
um
any particular quarter happened years
ago so it's not you know there's there
aren't that many knobs you can turn
during a quarter I mean you can but
they're very they're like eating your
seed corn if you turn those knobs you
don't want to do that and so uh it's
it's uh uh you know people uh I think if
you focus on the controllable inputs to
your business instead of the outputs in
the long term you get better results so
the the Benjamin Graham quote here is
the in the
short term the stock market is a voting
machine in the long term it's a weighing
machine and I think people are well
advised to build a company that wants to
be weighed and not voted upon and that
means having good return on invested
capital and having you know lots of free
cash flow but if you said to me if I
said
here's a job I would reject if somebody
came to me and said Jeff I want your job
to be to
drive up the Amazon stock price and just
manage that directly now this might
sound ridiculous to some of you but many
companies actually do this they have
they actually go out and they try to
sell the stock that's kind of the final
output and it's much better to say okay
let's not do that that's not going to be
sustainable it's kind of a silly
approach
what are the inputs to a higher stock
price you say okay well pre-cash flow
and return on invested Capital inputs to
a higher stock price okay so let's let's
keep working backwards what are the
inputs to free cash flow and you keep
working backwards until you get to
something that's controllable
and a controllable input for free cash
that would be something like lower cost
structure and the back up from there and
you say okay well you know if we can
improve our picking efficiency in our
fulfillment centers and reduce defects
defects are very very costly it's
probably you know reducing defects at
the root is one of the best ways to
lower a cost structure and so
if you then that starts to be a job you
would accept you would say if you're you
know a reasonable person you would say I
have no idea how to uh drive up the
stock price I can't manage that directly
it's not a controllable input but I can
make your picking algorithms more
efficient and that will reduce cost
structure and then you know follow that
chain all along the way tell your
invention are inseparable twins
um you know it's everybody wants to be
inventive you know if you go talk to
Corporate America or any any institution
actually uh government agencies and so
on Innovation is something to be proud
of people like invention but the problem
is they don't like failure and you
cannot have invention without failure
um if you uh
to know where if you already know it's
going to work it's not an experiment
and only through experimentation can you
get real invention the most important
inventions come from trial and error
with lots of failure and and the failure
is critical and it's also embarrassing
and so that's why people and when we're
kids
we always are doing child error and
we're never embarrassed you know if you
watch a little toddler and they will try
for hours to put a square peg in a round
hole and it never works but doesn't keep
trying and they try things like that and
that's how they learn and uh and and we
all have that when we're little and then
as we get older somehow it's not as cool
as you get older to fail and to fall
down it looks clumsy and so we get in
our grooves we have a set of expertise
and skills it's kind of comfort zone and
you have to constantly push yourself to
say no I don't care about failure in
fact if you know I say at Amazon we have
to grow the size of our failures as the
size of our company grows we have to
make bigger and bigger failures because
otherwise none of our failures will be
needle movers and so I would see it as a
very bad sign over the long run if
Amazon wasn't making larger and larger
failures and if you do that all along
the way
that is going to protect you from ever
having to make that big you know kind of
Hail Mary bet that you sometimes see
companies make right before they fail
and go out of existence the most
influential people in my life were my
grandparents and I have a my mother had
me when she was 17 years old she raised
me with my grandparents help and she was
still in high school when she had me
that was not cool in Albuquerque New
Mexico in 1964 but she did an incredible
job but I was lucky because I had not
just her but I had she re she married my
father when I was about four years old
he has been a huge influence in my life
but my grandmother and grandfather were
like second set of parents for me and
you learn different things from them
because they're at a different stage of
life and they know different things
they're calm about certain things it was
a huge gift to me my grandfather was a
had a ranch in Texas and I spent all my
Summers there from like Age 4 to 16 and
he was the most
self-reliant person he did all his own
Veterinary work all the things I mean
and to observe him solve problems and
figure out how to do things with no
tools and no resources and you know very
small amounts of money it was a huge
education from an early age so we were
very like one of the things that you I
know people who have they don't have
great family situations and sometimes
they break that cycle and they're the
ones who pull out of it those people are
the ones I reserve my highest admiration
for as the owner of the post I know that
at times the post is going to write
stories they're going to uh make very
powerful people very unhappy and you're
upset if they are writing critical
stories about Amazon which they do no
I'm not upset at all when I first bought
the pictures
and I'd never I would be humiliated to
interfere I would be so embarrassed I
would
I would turn bright red and it is
nothing to do with um I don't even get
so far I just don't want to for me it
would feel icky it would feel gross it
would feel it would be one of those
things when I'm 80 years old I would be
so unhappy with myself if I interfered
why would I I want that paper to be
independent Amazon one of the things we
try to do is have multiple paths to yes
and so here's here's a little thought
experiment for you
if you are a junior
executive at Amazon and that if we if
Amazon did this in the typical kind of
corporate hierarchy way you had an idea
you need to get your boss
to green light that idea and then your
boss's boss needs to Greenlight that
idea and then your boss's boss's boss
needs to Greenlight that idea there are
probably five levels or more before that
idea gets the go-ahead
assume instead that you're an
entrepreneur with a startup company idea
and you need venture capital
you go to Sand Hill Road
and you go to the first Venture cap list
and they tell you no
you go to the second one and they tell
you no
you're maybe your 20th one tells you yes
you've got 19 no's and one yes and
you're still good to go
so that that Venture Capital model is
there's multiple paths to yes there were
20 people who could give you a yes and
it didn't matter how many gave you a no
so if you want Innovative thinking you
have to think about how can we get you
want hide you want a large number of
high judgment people empowered to Green
Light things you want multiple paths to
yes you want a system where as a junior
Air Force officer with a good idea
the first five people tell me no and
somehow I can still go pursue that idea
so you got to figure out that's an
organizational
um uh challenge that big organizations
have to figure out a way to do and by
the way I get you know
this happens all the time I'll say I
don't think that's a good idea but
somebody else will green light it and
I'm fine with that because usually the
cost of the experiments is pretty small
things only get expensive when they work
right once something works we're like
Whoa We need to double down on that two
Pizza teams is something that we've been
preaching at Amazon almost from the very
beginning and it's a simple idea which
is no team should be uh so large that it
cannot be fed with just two pizzas and
uh and so obviously to do great things
you need big teams but you need to
subdivide them and the reason that it's
so helpful is because there's a natural
we humans grew up around campfires of
telling each other's stories and you're
sitting at tables tonight that have
about 10 people at each table 10 people
maybe 12 people is the perfect size to
have a natural uh human coordination
without a lot of structure and if you
want to have a big group of 100 people
or 500 people uh organized you have to
have a lot of structure to make that
work and so if you can arrange to do big
things with a multitude of small teams
and that takes a lot of effort to
organize Subway but if you can figure
that out the communication on those
small teams will be very natural and
easy Warren Buffett has this great quote
he says you can hold a rock concert and
that's okay
and you can hold a ballet and that's
okay just don't hold a rock concert and
advertise it as a ballet investors come
in all shapes and sizes they have
different investment Horizons different
approaches different beliefs about what
the right kind of portfolio looks like
and so it's not one you know people use
Wall Street as a shorthand but there
isn't one type of investor they come in
all shapes and sizes and you have to be
super clear about what kind of company
you're trying to build what's your
approaches we laid that out in our 1997
annual shareholder letter we said we
were going to take big bets we said they
were going to fail we said some of them
hopefully were going to work we said we
were going to invest for the long term
that we were going to try to take
advantage of Market opportunities as
they arose and there's a certain kind of
investor who is aligned with that
approach and so again you can hold the
ballet or the rock concert and both can
work
just be clear about which one you are
are and then people can self-select we
don't meet with our biggest investors we
meet with investors who have low
portfolio turns
so
you know investors that have you know
many investors many investment funds
have very high portfolio turns they turn
their portfolio multiple times per year
they're not really investors they're
Traders there's nothing wrong with that
it's just a different thing but where
are you going to spend your time your
energy is one of the most important
decisions you get to make in life we all
have a limited amount of time where you
spend it and how you spend it is is just
an incredibly leveraged way to think
about the world and so if you're going
to spend time
you know uh explaining
the stock and or the company really we
don't really explain the stock we
explained the company to people used to
do it to people who are long-term
investors
um rather than Traders that's our point
of view when I'm 80 now 90 I have I want
to have minimized the number of regrets
that I have in my life and most of our
regrets right are acts of omission
they're things we didn't try it's the
path untraveled
um those are the things that haunt us
what do you say to employees when
you have obviously have some traders in
the stock are not happy and suddenly the
stock is down 25 percent after a quarter
so for well since 1997 at almost every
All Hands meeting we have two All Hands
meetings a year
at almost every All Hands meeting I
remind employees
that you know if the stock is up 10 this
month don't feel ten percent smarter
because when the stock is down 10 some
month you're going to have to feel 10
percent dumber and it's not going to
feel as good and so it's you know
ownership
is we give most of our compensation uh
is is done in terms of stock
compensation and uh and part and parcel
with ownership is a mentality of of
long-term thinking you know you owners
think longer term than renters do so I
have a friend who rented his house to
some tenants and instead of getting a
Christmas tree stand at Christmas they
just nailed the Christmas tree into the
hardwood floors of the house no owner
would ever do that and um but sometimes
that's a bad tenant you know they're a
good good tenants but that's a bad
tenant and it's because you know this is
the same old thing about you know nobody
ever washed a rental car and
um you know you take better care of the
things that you own and and uh but but
one of the responsibilities of ownership
and definitely deep inside the Amazon
culture is to think about the
fundamentals of the business and not the
daily fluctuations in the stock price
there's no information in it you shop on
Amazon and if you have something the
service you don't like yeah so do you
just pick up the phone call your team of
700 000 people and tell them I don't
like this change this oh you know what I
do so um I don't do this it doesn't
happen that often but if I get a
delivery that'll like maybe they're like
where it's package or something we have
regular meetings of the senior executive
team and I bring the box to the meeting
and when I walk in I haven't done this
in a while it's been a while but when I
bring in a box everybody in the room is
like oh no he's bringing in a box
because it's always some problem but
really the way I get feedback is to is
primarily from my email address is very
well known and I keep it well known and
I get hundreds and hundreds of emails
every day from customers and they always
have something interesting to say when
something goes wrong because we have
hundreds of millions of customers around
the world and no matter how good we are
we can still be better you can always be
better customers have a Divine
discontent and they teach you if you
listen into customers so we watch for
that and we see patterns and we can find
places where it's not working
something's going wrong and that's
really how I get the feedback is from
customer input and often you know on all
caps angry you ruined my child's
birthday because the gift didn't show up
on time and we take that and what you
really want to do is you take that it's
an anecdote it's a single example but
you need to find the root cause what
went wrong deep inside the system how
did this happen because then you can fix
it for everyone so that particular
problem will never happen again you
don't just fix the symptom you have to
fix the root cause and that's been the
secret to our operational success for 20
years what I want to achieve with blue
origin is to build the heavy lifting
infrastructure that allows for
the kind of dynamic entrepreneurial
explosion of thousands of companies in
space that I have witnessed over the
last 21 years on the internet
so when I think about the founding of
amazon.com
it it only could work so it would take
you back to 1995 July 1995 we opened our
doors and this is a 10 person company
I'm driving the packages to the post
office myself
and
we had we were sitting on a bunch of
heavy lifting infrastructure otherwise a
tiny company could never have started
amazon.com you couldn't do it for
example there was already a gigantic
Logistics Network called the U.S Postal
Service and UPS and FedEx that would
have been tens of billions actually
hundreds of billions of dollars of
capital that you would have had to have
laid out if you had to build a logistics
Network we didn't have to do that it
existed that heavy lifting was already
done
um the the the internet itself was
sitting on top of at that time uh the
long distance phone network again tens
of billions hundreds of billions of
dollars of capital put in place for
long-distance phone calls but repurposed
for the internet
um payment system there was already a
payment system we didn't have to do that
it was called the credit card and it had
been initially put in place for
travelers and so on and so on and you
can go through and what we were able to
do is take all of that heavy lifting
inference infrastructure and kind of
reassemble it in a new way and do
something new and inventive with it and
that's one lens through which you can
view the founding of amazon.com in space
today that is impossible on the internet
today you know two kids in their dorm
room can reinvent an industry that's how
how uh because you don't the heavy
lifting infrastructure is in place for
that to date two kids in the dorm room
can't do anything interesting in space
you know you could build a cubesat
there's not that much interesting about
Cube stats and the uh that may change
but right now there's this you need
there are certain laws of physics and
certain things you need size for and the
things need to be big we need to be able
to put big things in space at low cost
and so if I'm 80 years old and I can say
to myself that blue origin
did the heavy lifting you know I'm using
my Amazon winnings
to do a new piece of heavy lifting
infrastructure
um uh which is low-cost access to space
vehicles have to be reusable you can't
throw them away throw away space
Vehicles every time you're never going
to lower the cost so we're trying to
lower the price of admission into space
so that thousands of entrepreneurs can
then do amazing surprising things nobody
in 1995 that much just nobody in 95
predicted Snapchat you know it's what I
can't predict for you what amazing
entrepreneurs brilliant amazing
entrepreneurs will do in space but I
know if I give them low-cost access to
space some brilliant you know 22 year
old is going to figure it out it's one
of those things about what companies get
sustainable it's those that provide
platforms upon which others can build if
you Amazon doesn't Empower others
Empower others to do things so AWS is
like that Kindle Direct publishing is
like that are third-party selling
businesses like that fulfilled by Amazon
is like that every time you figure out
some way of providing tools and services
that Empower other people to deploy
their creativity
you're really onto something I can do
some things that Amazon
that are would be hard for other people
to do only because of my history with
the company and my as the company has
grown of course my job has changed very
much and it has my main job today is I'm
kind of the I I I work hard at helping
to maintain the culture you know a
culture of high standards of operational
excellence of uh you know of
inventiveness of willingness to fail uh
willingness to make bold experiments I'm
the I'm I'm you know I'm the guy I'm the
counterbalance to the institutional no
who can say Yes
um but I won't you know I'm not going to
be here forever Amazon is a really uh
the many of the traits that make Amazon
unusual are now deeply ingrained in the
culture in fact if I wanted to change
them I couldn't if I decided
tomorrow I wish Amazon did less
pioneering and More close following
I couldn't do it the culture is
um is you know cultures are
self-reinforcing and that's a good thing
um you know the the people who come to
the company
we get sometimes people come to the
company and they can't they find Amazon
very boring because we don't have enough
you know competitive Zeal you know we
don't wake up some annual planning
processes and so and some companies
literally start with who are our three
biggest enemies
and then you know here's how we're going
to hold them at Bay or defeat them and I
we don't have such a list at Amazon it's
not how our annual planning process
works and so but if you're on the other
hand if you're the kind of person who
gets up in the morning and says in the
shower time you know what can we invent
for customers and what can we do
differently and how can we improve that
experience and so on so on then you know
then it's going to be a playground is
there I still run into work by the way I
took my family on vacation
to France my wife's extended family
there are about 20 of us and we had an
unbelievably good time great food
everything were there for a week I got
back to Seattle and I ran into the
office I'm having so much fun as number
one on the list we're talking to Steve
case yesterday and he had been number
one and a couple of years later he was
not on the list well you're making me
really nervous no no don't be nervous
just tell me what could happen that
would do that to you and Amazon and how
do you prevent that do you worry it
could all come unraveled well I kind of
have this experience kind of already
happened to me because you put me on the
cover of Time Magazine as person of the
year in 1999 and about a year later the
internet Bubble Burst I think Amazon
stock went from 113 dollars a share to
six or something like that
so these things happen the thing for
companies is you need to be
um if you
Nimble and robust so you need to be able
to take a punch and you also need to be
quick and and and Innovative and and
doing new things at a high speed that's
that's the best defense against the
future and you have to always be leaning
into the future if you're if you're
leaning away from the future the future
is going to win every time to be
Innovative you have to experiment
if you want
to have more invention you need to do
more experiments per week per month per
year per decade it's that simple you
cannot invent without experimenting
and here's the other thing about
experiments
lots of them fail
if you know it's going to work in
advance
it is not an experiment
and what happens in big organizations
that Amazon's a big organization now too
the Air Force is a big organization
is that we start to confuse
experimentation with operational
excellence
so
we you know operational excellence is
one of our four key principles that
Amazon
we're building a fulfillment center
we've built over 150 large fulfillment
centers around the world now
we know how to do that
that is not an experiment
if we build the 151st fulfillment center
and screw it up
that's just a failure
that's not the kind of failure we're
seeking we want failures where we're
trying to do something new untested
never proven that's a real experiment
and they come in all scale sizes there's
your completely massive and globally
dominant Commerce business first party
and third party there is AWS Amazon web
services which came out of nowhere and
it's now massive you're in a hardware
business including Echo and Kindle and
and the phone grocery delivery payments
TV shows you're now making TV shows
advertising Jeff how can you possibly do
all of that exhausting me how can you
possibly do all of that and do it okay
even okay let alone good
so I think one way to think about this
is what are you really focusing on so
um you know I'm focusing on those things
that I think make Amazon unusual
a genuine customer Obsession so like
every single thing you just mentioned
when you know when our senior Executives
sit down and review those programs
they're looking for customer Obsession
why did we expand into things like
Electronics tools and kitchen since
those businesses are not today
profitable and the answer is that um
that it increases our addressable Market
size so we can ultimately build a much
larger Company by entering into those
new product categories and and second
while it's true that those new
categories which are only three years
old and by the way Electronics Tools in
kitchen is now a 600 million dollar
business at amazon.com which makes it
one of the largest on a standalone basis
it's probably in the top four or five
e-commerce companies anywhere in the
world so that business is growing and
growing very rapidly and has it one of
the big advantages it has a huge
audience of early adopters which is why
companies like Segway choose us as the
exclusive launch platform for products
like that because really early adopters
are the kind of people who buy stuff
like this
um so it's uh uh but that business
ultimately will be Electronics in
particular in my opinion will be our
largest most profitable business one day
when you start a new business there are
certain fixed costs that come along with
starting that business and then the
business has to reach enough scale so
that the profit from the business the
variable profit can cover those fixed
costs the best advice and give somebody
is do something that you think is
interesting
and let the waves catch you you know
something that I see people do which I
don't think is a is a good idea is they
try to chase the current thing I saw
this so much in 1997 and 1998 1999 with
respect to the internet there were you
know in 94 and 95 and 96 97
the mostly the people who were you know
the kind of the earlier you get the more
true this is but you know the people who
were sort of looking at this space and
starting companies were genuinely
interested in it they thought it was
really cool
um by the time you got to 1999 like
doctors were stopping you know like
screw that doctor thing I'm going to
start a.com company you know and so um
that really made no sense whatsoever you
know people were sort of abandoning the
things they were genuinely interested in
trying to catch a wave and whenever you
try to catch a wave you're almost always
too late
um so it's it's better to just I mean if
you're paddling after it you basically
have to wait in place and let it come to
you one of the unusual things that we do
in the kennel device business is we sell
our hardware near Breakeven and so we
make money when people use the device
not when they buy the device and that is
very aligning with customers if I buy a
device and I put in my desk drawer and
never use it then Amazon doesn't deserve
to make any money likewise it causes us
to have the right kinds of behaviors so
for example if we're not making money
when people buy the device then we don't
need people to be on the upgrade
treadmill they can we have people who
are still using five-year-old Kindle
ones and we're perfectly happy about
that
AWS is very similar because it's a pay
as you go
service we are not incented to get
people to over buy Hardware to operate
at low utilization rates
our point of view on this is if we can
arrange things in such a way that our
interests are aligned with our customers
than in the long term that will work out
really well for customers and it'll work
out really well for Amazon my view is I
don't even like the phrase
work-life balance I think it's
misleading I like the phrase work life
Harmony
because I know that if I am energized at
work happy at work feeling like I'm
adding value
um part of a team whatever energizes you
that makes me better at home it makes me
a better husband a better father and
likewise if I'm happy at home
it makes me a better employee a better
boss all the things it's not about it's
not primarily about there may be crunch
periods where it's about the number of
hours in the week but that that's not
the mo that's not the real thing usually
it's about do you have energy and is the
is your work depriving you of energy or
is your work generating energy for you
and you know there are people everybody
in this room knows people you who
fall into these two camps you're in a
meeting and the person comes in the room
some people come into the meeting and
they add energy to the meeting other
people come into the meeting and the
whole meeting just deflates and those
people just they they drain energy from
the meeting and you have to decide which
of those kinds of people you're going to
be are you going to add energy
um the same thing at home and the same
thing at home and it's so it's a wheel
it's a psych it's a flywheel it's a
circle it's not a balance because a
balance that's why that metaphor is so
dangerous because it implies there's a
strict trade-off and you could be out of
work have all the time for your family
in the world but really depressed and
demoralized about your work situation
and your family wouldn't want to be
anywhere near you they would wish you
would take a vacation from them and so
it's not about the number of hours not
primarily I suppose if you went crazy
with you know 100 hours a week or
something yeah that maybe right maybe
there are limits and the probably I've
never had a problem and I think it's
because both sides of my life give me
energy and that's what I would recommend
that's what I do recommend to interns
and execs why not stick to the knitting
so and and my point of view on sticking
to the knitting is that it's not the
right thing for most businesses to be
that focused it's true that you hone
skills in a business you learn to be
really good at a few things and you do
want to extend out from those skills but
your customer needs change slowly over
time and you have to learn new skills on
behalf of your customers so basically
our customer we had a bunch of readers
as customers people who love to read and
they were they didn't know it our
customers they weren't asking directly
but basically they were saying to us
you're going to have to learn a new
skill you're going to have to stretch
and learn how to manufacture Hardware so
that you can continue to serve me 10
years from now that's what our customers
were telling us and and that's good if
businesses
you know try new things and stretch
their muscles and and and and put
themselves in uncomfortable situations I
think one of the reasons that businesses
stick to the knitting is because it's
way more comfortable a couple of other
things that are essential for Innovation
and invention that are not as fun
one of them is you have to have a
willingness to fail
you have to have a willingness to be a
misunderstood for long periods of time
if you do something in a new way
I don't care what it is
people are initially going to
misunderstand it relative to the
traditional way and they will
they'll be well-meaning critics
who you know genuinely want the best
outcome but they're worried about this
new way
and there'll also be of course
self-interested critics
who have a vested interest
in the traditional they have some Profit
Stream tied to the traditional way
um but but doing things and if you want
to if you never want to be criticized
for goodness sake don't do anything new
so it's it's it's okay though if you
have a willingness to be misunderstood
for long periods of time if you have a
willingness to fail
then what you can do is you can ramp up
your rate of experimentation so
successful invention a successful
invention is inventions that customers
care about
it's actually relatively easy to invent
new things that customers don't care
about
but successful invention
if you want to do a lot of that you
basically have to increase your rate of
experimentation
and that you can think of as a process
how do you go about organizing your
systems
your
people all of your assets your own daily
life and how you spend time how do you
organize those things to increase your
rate of experimentation because not all
of your experiments are going to work
you need people who and this is very
tricky you need people who are experts
in a certain domain area because the
world is so complex today it's really
hard to invent something if you're if
you're not an expert if you don't have
the underlying tools at your disposal
and know what's going on you can't you
know invent something in neurosurgery
without knowing something about
neurosurgery
it's just going to be very difficult
because we're very Advanced and that's
true in every every field of endeavor
but to really be an inventor you have to
combine that expertise with The
Beginner's mind you have to have a
certain
childlike ability to not be trapped by
your expertise and that fresh look that
beginner's mind once you're an expert is
unbelievably hard to maintain but great
inventors are always looking they have a
certain Divine discontent and they they
may have seen something a thousand times
and still it occurs to them that that
thing even though they're accustomed to
it could be improved and that's you know
you have to look for people like that
and I also think cultures support that
you know you can't even if you're that
kind of person
if you're in a culture that doesn't
support failure you know willingness to
fail is critical for invention
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time you know most inventions
don't really work that well in the
beginning they're clumsy they're little
toddlers they're always falling and
tripping
um and so you have to have a a a culture
in your organization that supports this
kind of stumbling and wandering uh you
know you want just because you're
wandering doesn't mean you're lost and
that's a really important thing to keep
in mind when you're trying to invent I
tell senior executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird I think false uh
idea that CEOs I'm a CEO there's this
false idea that CEOs are under the most
stress
well I look at that I'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress from
the very beginning
in 1994 when I came across this fact
that the web was growing at 2300 a year
I was working on Wall Street very
specialized kind of Investment Bank
called a quantitative hedge fund a
company called D.E Shaw
and uh I uh when I decided I was going
to go do this crazy thing I went and
told my boss and he said well let's go
for a walk so we went on a two-hour walk
in Central Park
and uh he actually thought it was a good
idea it's a very smart guy his name is
David Shaw he's one of the few people I
know who has a fully developed left
brain a fully developed right brain just
a super smart guy and he said this is a
great uh idea but it would be a better
idea for somebody who didn't already
have a good job
um
and
um and uh that was actually a compelling
argument to me and so I went away he
convinced me to think about it for two
more days and it was very hard to make
that decision and
until I found the right framework in
which to make the decision and I think
because I know there are a lot of people
who are interested in entrepreneurial
activities out there I think this could
be useful
it's it's that it's the right framework
for me anyway to make the kind of
decision was a regret minimization
framework so I projected myself into the
future and I'm 80 years old and I'm
looking back on my life what do I want
to have done at that point want to
minimized all the regrets that I have
and I knew that when I was 80 there was
no chance that I would regret having
walked away from my 1994 Wall Street
bonus or any of that kind of thing I
wouldn't even remember that but I did
think there was a chance that I might
regret not having participated somehow
and this thing that I thought was going
to be very exciting called the internet
and uh and I also knew that if I tried
and failed I wouldn't regret that so
once I thought about it that way it
become became incredibly easy to make
that decision what's going to change in
the next 10 years
and that is an interesting question it's
a very common one I almost never get the
question what's not going to change in
the next 10 years and I submit to you
that that second question is actually
the more important of the two because
you can build a business strategy
around the things that are stable in
time and so as you pointed out in our
retail business we know the customers
want low prices
and I know that's going to be true 10
years from now they want fast delivery
they want vast selection it's impossible
to imagine a future 10 years from now
where a customer comes up to me and says
Jeff I love Amazon I just wish the
prices were a little higher
you know how you I I love Amazon I just
wish you delivered a little more slowly
impossible and so the effort that we put
into those things
spinning those things up
we know the energy we put into it today
will still be paying dividends for our
customers 10 years from now and so those
when you have something that you know is
true even over the long term you can
afford to put a lot of energy into it on
AWS
the Big Ideas are also pretty
straightforward it's impossible for me
to imagine that 10 years from now
somebody is going to say I love AWS I
just wish it were a little less reliable
or I love AWS I just wish you would
raise prices
it should be a little more expensive
or I love AWS and I wish you would
innovate and improve the apis at a
slightly slower rate
none of those things you can imagine and
so the Big Ideas in business are often
very obvious but it's very hard to
maintain a firm grasp of the obvious at
all times
but if you can do that and can and
continue to spin up those flywheels and
put energy into those things as we're
doing with AWS over time you build a
better and better service for your
customers on the things that genuinely
matter to them you know as soon as
you're doing something new it's like
being a toddler all over again you get
up you fall down you get up you fall
down you get up you fall down and so
businesses need to do that same thing
they need to remember that it's not that
bad to fall down and it doesn't hurt
that much uh and I you know when we try
things like Amazon web services we don't
know that was going to work it has
worked really well but it's the kind of
thing that if it hadn't worked I always
tell people well guess what if something
doesn't work the day we stop doing it
all that will happen is our operating
margins will improve it won't be that
bad and and companies are get afraid I
think most
uh companies get criticized for
experiments that they tried that failed
but really companies should be
criticized for the omissions the things
they should have tried and didn't and
those almost always go unremarked that
blank sheet of paper stage is one of the
hardest stages and one of the reasons
it's hard is because there's at that
stage there's nobody counting on you but
yourself you know one of the things that
is very motivating I mean today it's
easy because we've got you know millions
of customers counting on us and you know
thousands of investors counting on us
and then thousands of employees all
counting on each other but in that
beginning stage it's really just you and
you can quit anytime nobody's going to
care
and so you set about doing the simple
things first so you want to start a
company well the first thing you do is
you should write a business plan and so
I did that I wrote about a 30 page
business plan I wrote a first draft in
fact I wrote the first draft on the car
trip uh from you know from from the east
coast to the West Coast and that was uh
that is very helpful now the business
plan won't survive its first encounters
with reality
um it will always be different the
reality will never be the plan but the
the discipline of writing the plan
forces you to think through some of the
issues and to get sort of mentally
comfortable in the space you cannot
invent and Pioneer
if you cannot accept failure to to
invent you need to experiment and if
it's if you know in advance that it's
going to work it is not an experiment
and so that's a very important thing you
you know it's they're Inseparable twins
failure and invention and so you have to
be willing to do that and it's
embarrassing to fail
um you know it's always embarrassing to
fail but you have to say no that's not
how this works if I said to you
you have a 10 chance of a with a
particular decision a 10 chance of a 100
x return you should take that bet every
time but you're still going to be wrong
9 out of 10 times and it's going to feel
bad 9 out of 10 times and in in in with
technology the outcomes the results can
be very long tailed the it's very the
payoff is can be very asymmetric which
is why you should do so much
experimentation you know people
everybody knows that if you swing for
the fences you hit more home runs but
you also strike out more but with the
baseball that analogy doesn't go far
enough because with baseball no matter
how well you connect with the ball you
can only get four runs
the success is capped at four runs
but in business every once in a while
you step up to the plate and you hit the
ball so hard you get a thousand runs
and so when that when you have that kind
of asymmetric payoff and you know one at
one at back can get you a thousand runs
it encourages you to experiment more
it's the right business decision to
experiment more it's also better for
your customers customers like the
successful experiments I didn't need to
build a transportation Network it
existed already it was ups and the Royal
Mail and the U.S Postal Service and
Deutsche Post and so on and so on I
didn't have to build a
telecommunications backbone to connect
with my customers it was there it was
called the internet and in fact the
internet was resting on top of the long
distance phone network at that time you
guys remember the dial-up motive some of
you do some of you are too young to some
of you should go to a museum and see a
dial-up motive what was that sound yeah
and so
my one I I recently showed a group of
youngsters a pay phone I came across one
and I was like my God guys come over
here this may be the last one you have
to see it
um and uh so you know the point is that
Amazon was got to rest on top of we
didn't have to build a payment system it
already existed it was called the credit
card
um computers were already on every desk
thanks to you know Microsoft IBM and
apple and you know but what were they
being used for to play games not to buy
things on Amazon and so all that heavy
lifting was in place one of the key
things about lean you know defect
reduction being efficient not letting
defects travel Downstream in any process
if you're going to eliminate waste or as
the Japanese call it muda you have to
have information
and um
the data center has historically been an
information free zone as far as
application developers are concerned
you would write code
and you have no idea how it's consuming
resources you're too insulated because
you're in a pool of resources
and you can't meter it
one of the biggest still
unappreciated
benefits of AWS is that application
Developers
get a real sense of which inner loop is
driving all the cost
yeah and that's a big deal so that and
that's just starting to that's one of
the ways that that this approach to
infrastructure dramatically reduces
costs in our in our data center I mean
in our fulfillment centers and in our
customer service centers
we have
um uh we're always seeking to keep
defects from moving Downstream so this
is a you know a a principle that was
probably best applied in the early or
best first best applied by Toyota
um and they had this idea of what they
call the andon cord which basically any
factory worker could pull the cord and
stop the whole automobile manufacturing
line
and
for old school
auto manufacturing companies that was
considered crazy absolutely insane in
fact the opposite principle was
typically at work which is you did
everything possible to keep that line
running
and here Toyota flipped out on its head
and they said look anytime there's a
defect no matter how small they want you
to pull the cord and stop the whole line
and um
stopping things you know if you if you
do that in a line that has a lot of
defects initially you get a lot of and
on cord pulls and it's very expensive
and but over time if you use that
approach you eliminate the defects
closer and closer to the source and and
the people who are
fans of lean manufacturing and these
kinds of techniques
just as an Article of Faith although
there's a lot of evidence to support
this in very diverse industries that the
further a defect travels Downstream the
more expensive it becomes to fix
and so you want to you want to stop
those things you don't want them to
repeat and happen over and over
invention is not disruptive only
customer adoption is disruptive at
Amazon we've invented a lot of things
that customers did not care about at all
and believe me they were not disruptive
to anyone
so it's only when customers like the new
way that anything becomes disruptive and
so really it's just saying that you want
to you know if somebody comes to you
with a business plan that they claim is
disruptive you should ask them to
explain it to you in simpler language
and the simpler language is why are
customers going to adopt this
um why are they going to like it why is
it better than the traditional way just
find something that you're passionate
about I would definitely on the career
advice side the most important thing
about your first job out of school is to
pick a place where you think you're
gonna you're where you're learning per
unit time is going to be very high you
can optimize for a bunch of variables
and it can get very confusing you know
where it's location you know what's the
salary going to be and all those things
are worth considering they're all
important but make sure you pull back
after you've done your analysis and say
am I also picking the place that I
believe my learning per unit time is
going to be the fastest and you learn
much more from a best practices company
than you you do you learn no matter
where you go so if you go work for
somebody you're like God these people
are all crazy this is insane you'll
learn a lot of negative lessons that you
can use later and you cannot do those
things but that process of elimination
method takes a long time so it's better
to try and find a place that has really
high hiring standards some of the basics
especially you know a place that's
trying to recruit only the you know the
you know a is higher A's and B's higher
C's and C's higher D's so you've got to
hire only A's and you need to pick a
company that's doing those kinds of
fundamental practices well because then
you'll learn so much it'll set you up to
do other things so I would say that's
probably the best career advice I give
when you look at the kinds of things
that you want to be able to do with your
voice uh you know it it changes for for
those of you who have used an echo the
fact that it's always on that you never
have to charge it it's always sitting
there ready in your kitchen or your
bedroom or wherever you put it the fact
that you can talk to it and and Natural
Way removes a lot of barriers a lot of
friction a lot of like little tiny
pieces of friction to be able to do
things to ask what the weather is it's
easier than taking your phone out of
your pocket and what what has what
people have found over and over again is
that by removing the tiniest amounts of
friction from ordinary activities really
people appreciate that and and it
improves customers lives sometimes you
know we we expand into new areas in two
ways one is kind of you know from from a
customer need we will work from a
customer need to the skills that we need
and the other one is skills forward from
a skill set we have to a new set of
customers so Kendall is an example of a
customer need and you know so we don't
have any hardware skills this we've been
doing this for 10 years now but we'll go
back and we'll go if you go back and
have 10 years we had no Hardware team we
had to hire somebody to lead our
Hardware group and then build a harbor
team and build some institutional
competence at it and so on
that um that's a customer need backwards
approach and then skills forward a great
example of that is Amazon web services
we had the skills to do AWS we had
probably more distributed computing
expertise than anybody else in the world
because of the transactions transaction
systems are so complicated and hard to
build and we had a service oriented
architecture of great complexity
probably before anybody else and so we
saw we could kind of because we were
doing that we could kind of see the
future a little bit and decided to build
AWS which has turned into you know a
huge business in its own right
and that is uh you know you if you were
always
business is very situational and so
rules of thumb are good but they have to
be applied to the right situation so
sometimes the old Maxim that you should
stick to the knitting is correct but
sometimes the adage that you should
stick to the knitting is wrong and uh
you know a senior Leader's job is to
figure out in which situation are you
there are a few things I think if you
want to be a Innovative company that you
you have to do first of all I think
Innovation is a point of view you have
to actually select people that are part
of the company who want to innovate and
explore
um being a pioneering
company and an Explorer company isn't
for everybody some people wake up in the
morning and they get their uh energy the
thing they think about in the shower as
they start their annual planning process
or however you want to think about it
with who are the three companies that
we're going to kill this year that's the
Conqueror mentality and it's a
competitor focused mentality instead of
a customer focused mentality
and there's nothing that that mentality
can succeed by the way so I'm not
claiming you know the pioneering
Explorer approach is the only effective
one
um but when you've when you attract
people who have the DNA of pioneers and
the DNA of explorers you build a company
of like-minded people who want to invent
and that's what they think about when
they get up in the morning how are we
going to work backwards from customers
and build a great service or a great
product
you you you that's uh that's a key
element in to to invention okay and that
part is Fun by the way so if you're the
right kind of person and you like to
invent you like change uh and you
everything you see as you move about the
world you think how it could be improved
we are uh can we be
let's take China and India very
separately so uh we are winning in India
very very uh well
um uh we have an amazing leader there a
guy named Ahmet who has been at Amazon
for 15 years and you know here in the
U.S we moved back to India four or five
years ago to start Amazon India and that
team is is doing well they have passed
Flipkart they are the leader in India
now so that is you know similar to Japan
Germany uh the UK France those countries
are you know very in China the leader is
JD and uh we have we are totally
adapting our strategy in China we cannot
run our normal playbook in China it has
to be specialized and different so we're
doing that we have always had and it's
been from the very very beginning you
can go back and read our 1997
shareholder letter uh and the the core
of the company is customer Obsession as
opposed to competitor Obsession and that
works really well for us it's a uh I
think that the advantage of being
customer focused is that customers are
always decide satisfied they always want
more and so they pull you along if
you're trying to serve them they pull
you along whereas if you're competitor
obsessed if you're a leader if you're
the leader you know you can kind of look
around and you see everybody running
behind you maybe you slow down a little
and customers are always pulling you so
I think if you want to be pioneering if
you want to be inventive if you want a
culture that is experimental then you
want to be customer assessed rather than
competitive or obsessed every time I
hear a story about Obama's father I get
more and more intrigued and want to meet
him and he's one of these guys who you
know you Ahmed has done all these
incredibly impressive things in his life
and somehow I get the impression that
ahmed's father is completely unimpressed
by all of these things and so the more I
learn about amit's father the more
Curious I get and this has been going on
for two decades and tomorrow night I get
to have dinner with amit's father
I I hope Amit dad is impressed by Jeff
[Laughter]
uh special guest here Lauren welcome to
India thank you for being here Priya
wonderful chatting with you backstage
and uh tell me have you seen any
perceptible change in India apart from
the traffic when you came last apart
from the traffic you know it's
interesting I um so I guess the I came
the first time I came to India was about
11 years ago one of them is you have to
have a willingness to fail
you have to have a willingness to be a
misunderstood for long periods of time
if you do something in a new way
I don't care what it is
people are initially going to
misunderstand it relative to the
traditional way and they will
they'll be well-meaning critics
who you know genuinely want the best
outcome but they're worried about this
new way
and they'll also be of course
self-interested critics
who have a vested interest
in the traditional they have some Profit
Stream tied to the traditional way
but but doing things and if you want to
if you never want to be criticized for
goodness sake don't do anything new
so
it's it's it's okay though if you have a
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time if you have a
willingness to fail
then what you can do is you can ramp up
your rate of experimentation so
successful invention a successful
invention is inventions that customers
care about
it's actually relatively easy to invent
new things that customers don't care
about
but successful invention
if you want to do a lot of that you
basically have to increase your rate of
experimentation
and that you can think of as a process
how do you go about organizing your
systems
your
people all of your assets your own daily
life and how you spend time how do you
organize those things to increase your
rate of experimentation because not all
of your experiments are going to work
you cannot invent and Pioneer
if you cannot accept failure to to
invent you need to experiment
and if it's if you know in advance that
it's going to work it is not an
experiment
and so that's a very important thing you
you know it's they are inseparable twins
failure and invention and so you have to
be willing to do that and it's
embarrassing to fail
um you know it's always embarrassing to
fail but you have to say no that's not
how this works if I said to you
you have a 10 chance of a with a
particular decision a 10 chance of a 100
x return you should take that bet every
time but you're still going to be wrong
9 out of 10 times and it's going to feel
bad 9 out of 10 times and in in in with
technology the outcomes the results can
be very long tailed the it's very the
payoff is can be very asymmetric which
is why you should do so much
experimentation you know people
everybody knows that if you swing for
the fences you hit more home runs but
you also strike out more but with
baseball that analogy doesn't go far
enough because with baseball no matter
how well you connect with the ball you
can only get four runs
the success is capped at four runs
but in business every once in a while
you step up to the plate and you hit the
ball so hard you get a thousand runs
and so when that when you have that kind
of asymmetric payoff and you know one at
one at back can get you a thousand runs
it encourages you to experiment more
it's the right business decision to
experiment more it's also better for
your customers customers like the
successful experiments we all have
adversity in our lives you I I would I
would I doubt if you really you know if
you know somebody any friend or anybody
that you talk to
um there's no lack of adversity and the
uh and by the way that's good because
it's what teaches us how to get back up
you fall down you get back up it always
happens and you know you get certain
gifts in life and you want to take
advantage of those
um but you I guess my advice on
adversity and uh success would be to be
proud not of your gifts but of your hard
work and your choices so you know you
may be the kinds of gifts you get like
you know you might be really good at
math it might be really easy for you
that's a kind of gift but practicing
that math and taking it to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat that's a choice
you can't really be proud of your gifts
because they were given to you you can
be grateful for them and thankful for
them and but your choices you choose to
work hard you choose to do hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of if you want to be an inventor of any
kind inventing a new you know a new
service offering for customers or a new
product or anything
the being an inventor requires because
the world is so complicated you have to
be a domain expert I mean in a way even
if even if you're not the beginning you
have to learn learn learn
enough so it should become a domain
expert but the danger is once you become
a domain expert you can be trapped by
that knowledge and so inventors have
this paradoxical ability to have that
you know ten thousand hours of practice
and be a real domain expert and have
that beginner's mind have that that look
at it freshly even though they know so
much about the domain and that's the key
um to inventing you have to have both
and I think that is intentional I think
all of us have that inside of us and we
can all do it but you have to be
intentional about it you have to say
yeah I am going to become an expert and
I'm going to keep my beginner's mind so
your question is you know did I kind of
anticipate what would happen over the
last 22 years at Amazon and the answer
is God no so you know Amazon started as
a very small company it was me and a few
other people I was driving all the
packages to the post office myself in my
1987 Chevy Blazer
um and uh when I raised money for Amazon
I had to raise a million dollars which I
raised from 22 different investors 50
000 each they got twenty percent of the
company for uh for the million dollars
and
um uh it was a 40 people told me no so I
had to take 60 meetings to get 20 yeses
the first question was always what's the
internet and I had to walk through that
and this was 1994 early 95. and so did I
anticipate you know fast forward to
today and and the current version of it
no it has been one foot in front of the
other and I think that that is true for
most businesses where you kind of
proceed adaptively it's step by step you
figure it out you have a success and
then you kind of double down on that
success and you figure out what what
else you can do what customers want ever
since I was five years old that's when
Neil Armstrong stepped onto the surface
of the Moon I've been kind of passionate
about space Rockets rocket engines space
travel I became a science fiction reader
and I've always known that I wanted to
uh you know do something having to do
with space and I've spent a lot of time
thinking about it for really almost my
whole life
and that's one of the things you guys
will find that you have passions and
having a passion is a gift I think we
all have passions and you don't get to
choose them they pick you but you have
to be alert to them you have to be
looking for them and when you find your
passion it's a fantastic gift for you
because it gives you Direction it gives
you purpose you could have a job or you
can have a career or you can have a
calling and the best thing is to have a
calling and if you find your passion
you'll have that and all your work won't
feel like work to you ask everybody to
not think in two to three year time
frames but to think in five to seven
year time frames to not think about when
somebody says to me congratulates Amazon
on a good quarter which is a very common
thing to say you meet somebody they're
being nice they looked at your financial
results for the quarter to a good
quarter I say thank you but what I'm
thinking to myself is that quarter all
that those quarterly results were
actually pretty much fully baked about
three years ago and so like today I'm
working on you know a quarter that is
going to happen in 2020 not next quarter
next quarter for all practical purposes
is done already and it's probably been
done for a couple of years and so if you
start to think that way it changes how
you spend your time how you plan where
you put your energy and and your ability
to look around corners gets better so
many things improve if you can take a
long term by the way it's not natural
for humans so it's a it's a discipline
that you have to build the um the kind
of you know get rich slowly schemes or
not big sellers on
infomercials you know it's uh and so
that's something that you have to sort
of Steal yourself for and discipline and
teach you can choose we all get to
choose our life stories and it's the
choices that Define us not our gifts
everybody in this room has many gifts I
have many gifts you can never be proud
of your gift gifts because they're gifts
they were given to you you might be you
know tall or you might be really good at
math or you might be extremely beautiful
or handsome or you know they're or
they're many gifts and you can only be
proudly of your choices because those
are the things that you are that you're
that you are acting on and one of the
most important choices that each of us
has and you know this just as well as I
do
is you can choose a life of ease and
comfort or you can choose a life of
service and adventure
and when you're 80 which one of those
things you think you're going to be more
proud of you're going to be more proud
of having chosen a life of service and
Adventure I've always been uh focused
when I was in Montessori School
um the Montessori school teacher told my
mom that I wouldn't switch tasks and
um they and they got me to switch tasks
by picking me up including my chair and
just moving me to the new task station
I've gotten a little better about that
over the years but it's still task
switching is still a problem for me if
you want another amazing Jeff Bezos clip
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there